All I do is hurt people.
So it's better if I don't do anything!
You'll get no pity from me. If you want
to avoid pain, just curl up and die.
Crying now won't help!
You hate yourself, don't you?
That's why you hurt others.
You know that hurting others
hurts you more than it hurts them.
But no matter what lies ahead, it will be
the result of your own decisions.
That means something, Shinji!
It means you made a difference!
Don't lie to yourself, think about
what you can do, and make amends.
You're just a stranger, Ms. Misato!
You don't know anything about me!
So what if I am a stranger?
You just want to give up?!
If you don't do anything now,
I'll never forgive you!
I'll never forgive you
for as long as I live!
You won't always be who you are now.
You'll learn that you made mistakes
and regret them. That's me in a nutshell.
A cycle of false elation
and self-loathing.
But each time,
I made a little more progress.
Listen, Shinji, pilot your Eva again
and figure things out.
With the you who piloted the Eva.
Why you came here.
What you were meant to do here.
Figure out who you are now.
And when you've worked it out,
make sure you come back.
Promise me.
Okay...
See you soon.
That's how grown-ups kiss.
There's more in store when you get back.